we've been talking about 10 reasons to
go all in on YouTube and in part one we
are really talking about internal
reasons like build history and Legacy
have an archive to show your kids to
show future Generations become a Creator
not just a consumer grow personally and
all these benefits of the fact that when
you punch fear in the face and you start
a YouTube channel you honestly become a
different person it challenges you to
level up it'll actually affect other
areas of your life and if you let it you
truly will become a better leader a
better entrepreneur you'll be forced to
learn new skills you'll be forced to
solve problems but in part two I'm
excited to talk about the next five
reasons which are really external
reasons benefits to your business your
brand your bank account and the first
one is to get discovered one of the
reasons to start a YouTube channel in a
competitive World in a competitive World
on YouTube you might say I feel like
someone's already doing what I'm doing
that's true you might feel like I feel
like the world's noisier than ever
before there's more marketing messages
than ever before that's true but the
fact remains YouTube is still the best
place to get discovered it's still the
second largest search engine in the
world and it's an amazing place to even
start from scratch you know when you
study experts in the space it is amazing
that new people are starting new
channels and they are growing in six
months from zero to a thousand to ten
thousand and a hundred thousand
subscribers I think about Larry he's a
charter financial analyst he got his
first 1000 subscribers in 10 days when
he started his YouTube channel he's
about to cross a hundred thousand
subscribers and he's basically started
within the last year and so you didn't
have to start 10 years ago you'd have to
start five years ago you can still get
discovered today and you know what we've
learned on YouTube think about Justin
Bieber Justin Bieber proved that YouTube
can produce pop stars how did he get
discovered as a musician on YouTube so
the question is really what do you want
to be known for
what do you want to be discovered for
what do you want to happen do you want
more leads do you want more customers or
do you just want to build an audience
and later on you're going to figure out
how to monetize and have money for the
mission the key is knowing that you
should start a YouTube channel because
it's a powerful place to get discovered
it's a powerful place to expand your
network if you want to connect with
like-minded people you're looking to
forge and fortify powerful business
relationships life relationships
like-minded people in Ministry in a
non-profit in some kind of an
organization when you're creating
content and posting it on YouTube it can
lead to getting discovered and honestly
my story proves this out and countless
others you know I'm a small town kid
College Dropout I didn't have any
connections in Hollywood I grew up on
six acres in Arlington Washington with
nanny goat and a bunch of dogs I grew up
in Arlington Washington without any
formal media training without any formal
entrepreneurship or business training
and now my world has gotten larger and
expanded because I started posting
YouTube content I've been able to travel
around the world connect with some of
the most influential people and Business
and Entrepreneurship and I have people
know who I am why on the other side of
posting YouTube videos of also not
despising Small Beginnings of starting
small of being patient but of committing
to one thing and that is posting
consistent YouTube content so one of the
reasons to start a YouTube channel right
now and to go all in is to get
discovered secondly is to build your
personal brand your personal brand gets
stronger as you continue to post YouTube
content you know when people discover
your content or when you send it to them
now imagine right you got a client
you've got somebody that is considering
they want to work with you you send them
an email you say here's a YouTube video
where I expect explain a little bit of
our proprietary process here's a YouTube
video where I actually share a little
bit of how we've helped a client here's
a YouTube video that kind of shows a
little bit of one of the projects we
worked on when someone watches that they
get to know you
and your expertise is platformed that's
a chance for your reputation to get
known that's a chance for your authority
to be built it's a chance for people to
build trust with you these are the
elements of personal branding people are
actually spending time with you and
they're getting to know you it makes me
think of Levi Lasik who credits my book
YouTube Secrets which second edition is
out by the way and super excited uh
Benji and I updated the book 80 new
pages it's out on Amazon ebook physical
book you can get it on Audible as well
if you like audiobooks and we actually
tell Levi's uh story at the back of the
book because he read the first edition
and he started to take action on posting
real estate content on YouTube is
channels called living in Dallas and
it's a real estate Channel but one of
the things you told me besides the fact
that they did like 92 million dollars in
a year or something like that of Top
Line real estate Revenue which led to
2.3 million in commissions rough numbers
those are my approximate numbers but
crazy him as his partner Travis and Levi
from posting content it led to Crazy
business results but some of the stories
he was telling me was what would happen
is people that were moving to Dallas had
been binge watching his YouTube channel
so they're getting to know him they see
his expertise his expertise they see his
knowledge of the Dallas area they see
that he is consistent and knowledgeable
and they're getting to know little
nuances about him because when you hang
out with somebody just like you're
hanging out with me right now maybe even
listen to the think media podcast you've
probably been kind of getting to know me
in my weird quirks and dad jokes and you
know Cadence and all this other stuff
like we're spending time together
what would happen is people would
oftentimes move to Dallas and they would
he would close complete real estate
deals having never even met someone now
real estate's a big trust game you want
to get you want to build trust with your
agent you want to get to know them but
that was what had happened there was an
acceleration of trust because he was
already getting to know people they had
watched 50 videos 100 videos and so in
some cases he's closing contracts it's
all happening via DocuSign an email
but not just because there's some
gimmick to it it's because
YouTube content helps build your
personal brand people get to know you
they see your reputation they hear some
other client testimonials maybe if you
put those up whatever it is and so
committing to going all in on YouTube is
a wise move because building your
personal brand in an internet and online
age is one of the most valuable assets
you could ever have as an Entertainer or
as an educator or a business owner
it's a powerful reason to go all in
right now the next one is to make money
no doubt about it
creating consistent YouTube content can
be incredibly lucrative you know data
came out from influencer marketing Hub
that there's now two million Global
content creators earning six figures two
million right that the fastest growing
type of small business right now signal
fire discovered is
being a content creator they're kind of
talking about them as the new world of
entrepreneurs like work from home
startup companies oftentimes individuals
that are creating content and then
monetizing it Forbes discovered that the
crater economy is evaluated or value the
valuation of it right now is around 20
billion and that by the end of the year
it's going to be over a hundred billion
that is 5X growth that's happening right
now in just 12 months time there is
massive amounts of money flowing into
the Creator economy and so the
opportunity here and the reason to go
all in is to have this confidence to
know that there is money on the other
side of the hustle and effort it takes
to start a YouTube channel and that
money could be connected to you as a
content creator as a startup hobby
creator that maybe wants to share your
passion and entertain and eventually get
enough views so that YouTube pays you
eventually get enough use so Brands want
to send you free stuff and send you
money through brand sponsorships maybe
you start a patreon or Channel
memberships and maybe you're kind of on
that side of the crater economy on the
other side you're a business owner but
maybe business is tough maybe you don't
have enough customers or leads maybe you
realize that as you're growing your
business competition is rising as well
and if you want to stand out and be
different listen your business is going
to stand out among others if if
everything else is the same
but they don't have a presence on
YouTube that's educating and giving free
value and letting people get to know you
and putting out your reputation and
letting people understand your Authority
and your expertise through your personal
brand you're doing that and the other
competitor of yours is not doing that
you've got the advantage it is an
advantage to you to go all in on YouTube
right now the person with 50 to 100
YouTube videos platforming their
expertise has an advantage over the
person who's in the same industry who
has not done that the fact remains and
when you do that and you do it
intelligently and you connect it to a
Smart sales process and smart the lead
capture methods and an intelligent way
of setting it up to how it could be
connected to your product service and
services
you're going to generate more money it's
staggering and you know you may just be
starting and this may also sound like a
lot of information right now you may be
new to the think media podcast but just
coming from me heart to heart I just
transparently have a chance to sit in a
lot of really weird rooms like I I like
recently just went to Miami for this
invite-only event at um Cardone Ventures
super strange with like 50 other quote
unquote influencers whatever that term
means uh but I was in the room and I
think they added up the total top line
revenue of businesses in that room and
how much they were generating and it was
almost two it was almost two billion
dollars it was 1.96 billion dollars of
top line revenue from the entrepreneurs
in that room 99 of them are in marketing
social media and having YouTube channels
they're not YouTube Burrs they're
business owners but that are
understanding the power of Marketing
Online and of marketing on social media
and of marketing on YouTube I speak at
events like VidCon vidsummit traffic and
conversion Summit social media marketing
World different events I'm about to fly
to Atlanta and speak there and the
reason I share that is because cause I'm
in all kinds of rooms where you might
think oh this is only for a small group
you might think that this is there's
just like a few people doing this but
like I haven't really seen the
practicality of this we had through our
own event growth video live in Las Vegas
and person after person came up to me
now listen they came up to me and they
said hey five years ago I was at Grow
video live one
and now I'm doing eight million dollars
a year in our business
hey two years ago I discovered the
podcast and now I'm part time at my job
but I've got an extra few thousand
dollars coming in every month and I'm
creating content and impacting people
and I love what I'm getting to do
my friends this is real this is
practical I'm not trying to over hype it
I am just telling you that I have the
unique positioning to see oh my gosh
there is massive money in this industry
because I mean add it up a hundred
billion dollars this year 5x growth in
the crater economy that is going in
people's pockets that could be your
neighbor right there's a book called The
Millionaire Next Door that that that is
people that is impacting real families
real kids real people and even though
it's still weird at Thanksgiving dinner
when you know Uncle Ed is like what what
are you doing you're thinking about
posting videos online or yourself what
do you think you are some kind of an
influencer in the wild what the heck are
you doing you know you're like listen
okay I get it it's still kind of weird
it's still kind of weird to hold your
phone up or your camera up in public and
film something if you ever try to film
something somewhere it's people still
look at you strange it's still sort of
weird to press record and selfie it's
strange but it's real and friend it's
lucrative there is real money on the
other side of starting a YouTube channel
and building it intentionally and
strategically with smart methods
next to make an impact
one of the reasons you should start a
YouTube channel and go all in right now
and one of the reasons you should double
down if you're already on YouTube is
because you can make a real difference
to make a real impact I'm talking about
change lives I'm talking about raising
money I'm talking about raising
awareness for causes that matter
some of the things that I've been able
to experience you know the co-author of
our book YouTube Secrets Benji Travis um
him and his wife for seven eight nine
years did an event every holiday season
called dance sember and they'd get
together
different YouTube creators to dance for
24 hours and every time a goal was
raised every time 5K or 10K was raised
uh there was a DJ music would play they
would dance camera people they started
just with the webcam and a laptop
sitting on their fireplace with them and
their kids and I think they raised like
50 Grand
fast forward they've raised almost 2
million total I think there was years
where they raised a million in one year
from why using their influence what they
are they're family vloggers so all year
long they're blessed to be able to Vlog
and and create entertaining narratives
and story story lines from their family
they get to do brand deals and YouTube
ad Revenue but they also were like let
me use our influence to give back and
let me also rally others so they could
be a part of something where they can
commit to staying up for 24 hours
bringing their audiences through
different challenges and things that
they did for 24 hours where they'd have
different guests and they just gather a
bunch of creators together you see this
in the gaming industry sometimes big
influencers will come together but I
want to encourage you even if you have a
small Channel or you haven't started yet
you can make an impact the reason to
start is knowing that on the other side
of this there is an impact to be made
you know uh in in a day gone by Benji
and I started a channel called video
influencers we have interviewed now
hundreds of creators and we had a motto
that was you know build your influence
first which is like you gotta just start
and get a few subscribers and then you
gotta hit a thousand subscribers and
then you got to get to that ten thousand
and then start building your income
because you need money for the mission
because you might need to you gotta you
know work your day job hustle a little
bit get your channel going then you get
some money coming in and then reinvest
that money so maybe you could go
part-time or maybe you could go full
time or your business owner maybe your
online YouTube efforts are generating
enough income so you can hire that
full-time videographer that full-time
editor you need that income and then
ultimately though so you can make an
impact it's not just you can build
influence for yourself not just so you
can make income for yourself
and your family but what kind of
difference can you make in the world and
and I know you can you should maybe
start with impact first but I've just
learned
that you're not going to be able to
impact very many people if you can't
even afford to buy groceries because
you'll wither away and die before you
can truly make an impact in the world
so it really leads to impact so as Benji
and Judy built their influence they were
able to do Dan sember you look at Mr
Beast he's done all kinds of things but
he did like teen trees team trees was
this campaign where people are donating
money to plant a tree and they have
planted over 23 million 940
000 trees so far you can look up the
website team trees and that's cleaning
the world's air you know we need trees
we need to plant them and so that's
making a difference in all kinds of
different ways what do you care about
what moves you what what kind of
difference would you want to make and I
want to encourage you of course do it
right now where you are but this is one
of the ways to light a fire to say hey
the reason I want to start a YouTube
channel and commit to the challenges of
growing that YouTube channel is not just
for myself but it's for the difference I
want to make in the world it's for the
impact that I want to make it's for the
money I want to give away it's for the
resources I want to give away it's for
the lives that I want to change this is
one of the things that fuels me in
addition to
our business itself think media being a
place now that employs others other
people have kids Pace people's bills
through them working here hopefully they
get to have powerful experiences
recently we were able to take our entire
team and their spouses and children to
Disneyland and hopefully be a blessing
to our team but we also want to be a
blessing to the world for example we
partner with Compassion International we
sponsor 101 kids every single month
right now we're always trying to add
more and that includes housing and food
and education and in our case and our
passion discipleship we uh love to give
away a lot of money to our local church
and our local churches now in a couple
different states and different causes
that we care about that moves me it
actually lights me on fire because
personally I believe that the local
church is the hope of the world so I am
motivated to grow the business to
generate more income not because I need
another her car my 2016 Ford Explorer
Sport with 72 000 miles on it is
freaking amazing man I still love that
car it's got a moon roof and it's
turbocharged let's go I'll race you on
the highway but I won't break the speed
limit listen I don't need another car I
am motivated
by making a bigger impact
by who else can we hire by what else can
we do with thick media my friend Ruslan
hit I think a hundred thousand
subscribers and he did a multi-hour
stream maybe it was a 10 hour stream or
something or all day and he was having
people it was his birthday he celebrated
his birthday online he said hey for my
birthday give to charity water
I think he raised ten or twenty thousand
dollars for charity water to have whales
and other countries
um throughout having a bunch of guests
and I was a guest on a show and he
brought on like 20 of his friends listen
you can connect with others and make a
real impact our friends at vid IQ did a
major thing raising money for Ukraine a
lot of their team members on the vid IQ
team helping build that software that
helps you with YouTube a lot of their
team members were in Ukraine and so they
did a whole thing raising money and
awareness for Ukraine my question to you
is what matters to you what makes a
difference in what what would motivate
you and what kind of impact you want to
make and I want to encourage you that
one of the reasons to go all in on
YouTube and create content is not just
for the money you can give away
but it's also for the impact that the
content itself will make on the end user
you know I saw some people commenting
about the impact of our content at think
media
and uh Cajun Venture says this works I
have learned so much I have followed all
your tips and hit our first eight
thousand dollar YouTube month previously
we are around eight hundred dollars a
month that's amazing that's 10x growth I
do everything you say so keep them
coming thank you so again that's why we
do what we do at think media and the
think media podcast honestly it's the
content itself first it's the impact
hopefully in your life that the reason
we do this podcast is so you can start
on YouTube and grow on YouTube and
monetize your YouTube and get to 800 a
month and then follow the tips and get
to 8 000 a month and so the content
itself and for you it could be
encouraging people entertaining people
helping them with their mental health
helping them generate money helping them
like one of our students in our video
record Academy program Dr Andrea she
helps people with chronic pain that's a
real impact I know that's a challenge
I've gone through personally with
tendonitis and tendinos tendinosis and
repetitive strain injury I watched Dr
Andrea's Channel she makes a Major
Impact in my life our friend Justin
coves one of our VRA students uh sent a
message to Heather and said we just had
another successful launch of our digital
missionary Academy another 30 pastors
signed Dawn that's an impact and we talk
about this in our think media staff
meetings we don't just define success by
our customer success we think we are
most successful when our customers
customers are succeeding let me put it
another way because you might not have
customers we don't just measure success
by when our viewer or our listener
experiences success we want our
listeners listeners our viewers viewers
to have success it's about your audience
it's about the people you're going to
impact we at this point in our career at
think media we hope we are multipliers
we're trying to help you multiply and
impact more people we're trying to help
ten thousand purpose-driven people
create a full-time living doing what
they love while making a difference in
the world with online video on YouTube
this is a serious mission yes you got to
go full time because you need money for
the mission yes you got to pay your
bills because you need money for the
mission but we are serious about helping
purpose-driven people people that want
to make a difference bigger than
themselves people that want to make an
impact and helping them not just
generate money but ultimate ultimately
make a difference in the world all right
and number five which is actually 10 of
our two-part series and I actually have
a bonus one that I got to share with you
as well so stick around until the end
but uh but number five is create
Community one of the reasons to go all
in on YouTube is to create Community
what I've learned is that as you create
content on YouTube you will gather
people of similar interests whether you
do this through Channel memberships of
course as people subscribe but what I've
learned is that this leads to in-person
friendships and connections if you're on
YouTube long enough
eventually there's probably I mean and
that's up to you you might be like I
don't want to see anybody I'm an
introvert I don't want to go in public
that's fine it's entirely up to you but
what I've learned is that it's amazing
that a lot of online connections have
led to in-person relationships whether
that's meeting up at an event you know
we're based here in Las Vegas at think
media and we have a thing called
vegasinfluencers.com if you want to go
to vegasinfluencers.com you can sign up
all it is is just a database for when we
do local Las Vegas meetups we had to
send out an email to let people know
where the time and place is and
information about it and so if you're in
Vegas or you're in Arizona or California
or you just want to know
vegasinfluencers.com we have had 10
people 30 people 50 people we've had
people fly in for it and we've had these
incredible connections and and
meaningful moments with people because
we started a YouTube channel and we
started posting content on YouTube first
we've had people that have joined the
think media team John Nacarato who helps
us with brand deals he came to a Vegas
influencers Meetup that's when we first
met him now John and Tanya some of our
favorite people in the world at the time
of recording this just last night we
were together a barbecuing together
hanging out we met because of YouTube
and I start to think about how enriched
my life has been I met Heather Torres
actually on Twitter the host of the
think media podcast and the chief
operation officer and one of the content
creators of think media because I was
creating content on YouTube she reached
out and followed me when they moved to
Vegas and the rest is history and that's
a story for another day but because of
posting YouTube content my world has
gotten bigger my relationship network
has gotten bigger some of my best
friends some of the people that have
totally transformed my life and
hopefully I've transformed their life
and are all of our lives together have
gotten bigger friend this might seem a
little idealistic or a little bit like a
dream like man I just don't know if all
that could be true and I'm not even
saying what scale it will be all I am
saying is I know this that is this is
countless people's story that when they
punch fear in the face and they just
mustered the courage to start their
YouTube channel that their world got
bigger that online community turns into
in-person meetups and events that you
start to meet people you never would
have known you would meet you might
wonder I don't know if I could ever find
somebody who thinks like me or who'd
want to work like me who would want to
share this dream that I have or maybe
there's something you want to be a part
of you build your portfolio you build up
your channel you eventually collaborate
with somebody else there's some Synergy
that happens there the truth is this
though if you stay a consumer that won't
happen
but when you step into the creation game
then one of the things that happens is
you can create Community this is a
reason to go all in and you know that
I'm a small town kid
I grew up in a in Marysville Washington
in Arlington Washington and my world was
not that big but I as I began to just
post videos on YouTube I didn't know
that any of this stuff was going to
happen so you can just take it on the
authority of me now looking back over 10
years later and saying wow I'm just so
glad that I started to post videos and
that I kept learning and that I kept
investing in myself and that I just kept
saying yes and I kept you know doing
hard things and and working with
freelance clients and reaching out for
collaborations and getting denied for
collaborations and inviting people to be
interviewed and getting denied and they
don't want to be interviewed but then
also eventually getting a yes and going
to an event and sleeping in weird hotels
that the AC is broken and it's super hot
and muggy and just all the different
experiences that have happened over the
last 10 years but I've learned that
Community is created when you punch fear
in the face and start to channel and I
want to share one bonus tip with you as
well
to also encourage you for another reason
to go all in with starting YouTube but
as I recap number one if you missed part
one definitely listen to part one
because that was the five internal
reason number two uh these are the
external reasons to recap number one get
discovered number two personal branding
number three make money number four make
an impact and number five create
community and when you put all of these
together it's 10 reasons to go all in on
YouTube right now is it gonna be easy of
course not is there challenges yes
but it's worth it I believe you
internally be transformed and your
external world and business and brand
will be transformed as a result of
starting and committing to posting
consistent YouTube content but I want to
give you a bonus uh reason really quick
and also just encourage you if you have
haven't subscribed to the think media
podcast of course on audio just make
sure you're subscribed so they're always
being sent to your phone we're going to
be releasing some Audio Only episodes
um so you'll want to make sure if you're
just on YouTube definitely check out the
audio podcast because we're going to
have some audio only ones you know
wherever you listen to this though make
sure you're subscribed because coming up
I'm gonna have my friend Matt Bontrager
on the show and uh depending on actually
when this comes out you may actually
just go back and find this in the
archive because this already happened in
terms of the continuity of our episodes
But ultimately here's number 11 and
here's what Matt's going to be talking
about you should go all in on YouTube to
get tax advantages because you're
starting a small business when you start
a YouTube channel and you do it just as
a professional you actually don't have
to get an LLC now I'm not a CPA I'm not
a lawyer just as a sole proprietor you
can now start getting write-offs that
other people don't have because starting
a YouTube channel is starting a business
you can start writing off a camera
writing off home office space in your
home writing off a computer writing off
your office chair you can start writing
off travel to YouTube and educational
events you can start writing off dinners
with people you're collaborating with uh
and shooting YouTube videos with because
that's all part of your business certain
trips could become relevant write-offs
because you're creating content on the
trips it could be certain vehicles or
percentages of vehicles and things that
you're using now this is not Financial
advice it will be from Matt so I just
want to say in addition to everything
else definitely listen to part one and
listen and make sure you're subscribed
to the episodes that we're doing with
Matt bontragger because this is a
serious key I read a book called Rich
Dad Poor Dad and really helped me
understand that like taxes is one of the
biggest bills you were ever ever pay you
may not even think about it friend this
is a major key and we want to give you
more information and tips about this
from an expert CPA who we personally use
and he's going to be breaking everything
down